this one's really interesting we have
another example of occasional
voice of reason on fox news occasional
actual journalist
on fox news chris wallace calling out
another republican official for their
just obvious blatant pathetic hypocrisy
this time the target the victim i don't
know what you would call them the the
mark
is texas republican governor greg abbott
who
said nothing when donald trump was
president about all of the alleged
sexual abuse at migrant shelters when
donald trump was in office
but now all of a sudden that joe biden
is in office greg abbott
is claiming to care about allegations of
sexual assault at these migrant
detention centers so let's get right
into it and then
after this i'll remind you um something
very similar happened with chris wallace
just a couple of weeks ago
we'll look at that a little bit later
here's the clip of uh chris wallace
and greg abbott let's talk about those
dire consequences you made news this
week
reporting that there are cases of sexual
abuse
at the freeman coliseum in san antonio
texas that houses right now more than
sixteen hundred children
but the head of a nonprofit that
provides legal services to immigrants
said this
the only reason why abbott is now acting
like he cares about the children
in these facilities is for political
reasons
governor there were thousands of
complaints
of sexual abuse at migrant shelters
during the trump years
not to say that what's going on now is
right but we couldn't find one
instance of you complaining and calling
that out when president trump was
president
sure there are multiple differences
between what happened in the trump
administration and what is happening now
first the trump administration remained
in constant communication
uh with me and with my office and let us
know what was going on
second i saw reports about exactly what
you're talking about
and saw that those reports were filed
with federal agencies
the one that i talked about earlier this
past week
were reports that were filed with state
agencies
the texas health and human services
commission and the department of
protective
and child services which is basically
child protective services
and so we have a duty uh to respond
to any complaint about child sexual
abuse in texas
as well as to investigate it and that's
exactly what i did
to make sure it was addressed so abbott
says
there are multiple differences when
trump was president
there was really only one difference
which is trump was president then
and joe biden is president now that the
all of the other
differences that uh greg abbott cites
they're really distinctions with no
practical substantive difference and if
it's true
that now greg abbott is being notified
about this
and when it was trump he wasn't being
notified i would look at
whether the reason for that is in itself
politically motivated
every time this happens they always come
up
with meaningless semantic distinctions
that lack any substantive difference and
that's exactly what greg abbott did now
let me remind you the last one of these
that chris wallace did was a couple of
weeks ago
and he interviewed republican senator
tom cotton
and wallace asked tom cotton listen you
know now you're complaining
that with biden's coveted stimulus
prison inmates
received stimulus money they also
got stimulus money during donald trump's
first covet stimulus
and donald trump's second covet stimulus
and you voted for those
and tom cotton came up similarly with a
meaningless response
that has distinctions that really are of
no substantive importance whatsoever
take a look
here is one of your other complaints
about the
the covet relief bill take a look sir
look how crazy some of the democratic
ideas are i mean they had a chance
on saturday morning to stop checks from
going to prisoners
from going to the boston bomber for
instance and on that vote
they declined every single democrat
wanted to continue the practice of
sending checks to prisoners
but senator under two previous coped
relief bills that you
supported and voted for and that
president trump signed
prisoners also got checks in those bills
well chris that was obviously never
congress's intent the trump
administration irs and treasury
department
did not send checks to prisoners liberal
advocacy groups sued to try to force
that a liberal judge said they had to
last month was the for this month was
the first time we ever had a simple up
or down vote on whether those checks
should go to prisoners
and the simple fact is that every
democrat voted to keep sending checks to
prisoners
i don't think that's a smart idea i
suspect most americans don't either
again
there is no defense other than to say
you know chris that's right i'm playing
politics that's the truth
that's the real answer during covet
stimulus one and two
it wasn't our intent he says but this
time democrats
did want prison inmates to get the money
and then he says
this is the first time we had an up or
down vote and it passed
well that's because you guys controlled
the senate before
and you didn't want an up and down vote
on it but the up and down votes would
have essentially been the same both
times
it's always deflection it's pointing
fingers
and that's really the trump mantra that
a lot of these republicans
have adopted and perfected in some sense
so as far as chris wallace goes
good for him you know we've talked
before wallace tries to find
uh we can all find fault with any cable
news talking head if we want to
i get the impression that chris
wallace's intentions are generally good
that being said there is the
counterpoint
that whether chris is well intentioned
or not
acting in good faith or not his presence
at fox news provides cover a sort of
smoke screen
for people like tucker carlson and sean
hannity and for fox news to say listen
we've got a lot of different things we
have chris wallace and we have tucker
carlson and we have sean hannity
i take the position that it doesn't
matter and what i mean by that is
chris wallace is asking many of the
right questions and
sure he will be used by fox news for fox
to be able to say
we're fair and balanced we have news and
opinion we have
things that are more critical of the
biden administration support whatever
some of these right-wingers will see it
and by math
some fraction might realize wow these
republicans are really hypocrites
and wallace is the exception on fox he's
not the rule i get that
but i continue to believe that his
presence does more good than harm
overall
much like shepherd smith while he lasted
until he ended up just bailing out on
fox news
in terms of abbott and cotton and all of
these guys
they're dangerous they're completely
amoral if not
immoral um greg abbott's lieutenant
governor dan patrick you might remember
was the guy who early in the pandemic
said listen grandma would sacrifice
herself for the economy
by which he meant the stock market so
all of these guys have a very similar
i guess we'd call it a lack of a moral
compass tom cotton never saw
a double standard he could get away from
they're terrible
and any opportunity to possibly expose
them for what they are
even if it's coming during the exception
to the rule on fox news with chris
wallace
i think it's a good thing if you
disagree with me
let me know if you think the presence of
someone like wallace is a net negative
i i'm open to having my mind changed but
you're going to have to change it let me
know your thoughts
and we'll have more on this and other
such fox news incidents
on our instagram page you can find us on
instagram at david pakman show